नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि नेक्स्ट
एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
इंपोर्टेंट सीखने वाले हैं जो है
एडजेक्टिव्स के फॉर्म यह जो कंसेप्ट है ना
यह एकदम इंग्लिश की तरह है इसीलिए वह
इंग्लिश का सहारा लेकर सीखने वाले हैं
मतलब क्या कि देखो को सस्ता है को किस चीज
को टिप्स इतना ही सकता है को किस ऐड चीप
सी को एचसी से सस्ता है को किस चीज पर
देंगे इसी को सबसे सस्ता है को किस चीज
पेस्ट चीज पर चिप्स या सब को एकदम सिंपल
डिक्रीज क्या है जब चीप बोलते हो तो वह
पॉजिटिव डिग्री है दोनों इक्वल राइट जब आप
एक चीज दूसरी से ज्यादा अच्छी है बोल रहे
हो तो वह कंपैरेटिव डिग्री है और थर्ड कौन
सी है सुपर लेते हो कि सबसे अच्छी है MS
Word है तो पॉजिटिव है एग्जाम है
वो तो ए कंपैरेटिव है टेस्टी है तो सुपर
लेते हुए कंसेप्ट यह सब को जर्मन में चकली
शैंपू जर्मन में अगर आपको बोला यह चीज को
जर्मन में बोलते हैं बिल्ली बिल्ली या
बिल्ली जो जज एरिया में आप रह रहे हो तो
चीफ बस आपको अगर चीज पर बोलने जर्मन में
भी शेयर लगाओ बिल्ली घर और यहां पर अपने
चीज पेस्ट लगाया था वहां पर आम लगाओ
शुरुआत में और एंड मैच स्पेन आ बिल्ली
इस्टर्न तो आपको सबसे पहले क्या था को चीज
को किस्ट विलेज ओं
आप को किस चीज पे हमें क्या न खाएं ऐड
जर्मन में जो और वी लगाना को कि स्ट्रोब
इंग्लिश बीपी सी को किस जॉब लिक्विड सीन
कि सिमिलरली अगर आपको बोलना है किस चीज पर
डेन आपने ध्यान लगाया जर्मन में लगाओगे ऑल
कॉकपिट डिगर और इस पृथ्वी पर यह तो एंड
इजी है को किस चीज पेस्ट को किस आम
इलेक्ट्रॉनिक देखिए एक दम सिंपल है कि
जहां पर s.st था वहां पर जॉब भव्य चीरवा
चीपेस्ट अब इलेक्ट्रॉनिक्स ऐसे टेस्टिंग
यह करते हैं टेस्टी मतलब लेकर तो पहले से
करते हैं वीकली को किस टेस्टी को किस लेकर
को किस ऐड टेस्ट इयर्स पे को किस जो लेकर
भी टिप्स ई ई
12 लेकर की तैसी को कि टेस्टी अर्घ्य को
प्ले लिस्ट लेकर ऑल स्फियर्स को किस चेस्ट
को सिस्टम लेकर टर्नऑन इन एकदम सिंपल कुछ
भी नहीं है
कुछ भी नहीं है अभी तक को इंग्लिश में अगर
आपने देखा होगा आप जब कॉस्टली का करते हो
और असली का क्या करते हो कॉस्ट क्लियर
करते हो तो वह का आई यार करते हो फ्रेंडली
का फाइनल ईयर करते हुए का आईआर करती हूं
आशा है तो एक ऑप्शन है उससे भी बड़ी बात
है इंपोर्टेंट का क्या करते हो आप
इंपोर्टेंट अ नहीं करते मोर इंपॉर्टेंट
करते हुए थे मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट करते हो तो
लकी अली जर्मन में इतना भी रेगुलर नहीं है
जर्मन में क्या होता है कभी-कभी थोड़े से
यूरोप हमेशा प्यार और स्टैंड ही लगाओगे
थोड़े से रूप चेंज होंगे तो कही गई क्या
होता है गिरोह है रस मतलब बड़ा गुरुसर
आंगिरस टर्न ऑफ उन लॉक लग गया देखो स्टार
तैरकर आम चेक रिटर्न फिर से उम्र लग गया
और कुछ और थोड़े वर्ड्स है कि मैं थोड़ा
चेंज होता है और मतलब पूछा त्योहार आम योग
स्टैंड तो अज्ञेय ने थोड़ा चेंज हुआ पर
देखो यह थोड़े से
हैं इनमें से कुछ थोड़ा वोट की लिस्ट
मैंने आपको अभी यहां पर दिए है यह
जैसे-जैसे यूज करोगे वैसे आपको आता जाएगा
इस पार्ट एंड पार्सल आफ एनी लैंग्वेज जवाब
लैंग्वेज सीख क्यों तो उसके एक्सेप्शन के
साथ आप सीखते हुए बेसिक क्या है
इंपोर्टेंट याद रखना है कि वह एयर लगेगा
और हम स्टंट लगेगा कंसेप्ट ईयर सबको अभी
और चीज इंग्लिश में आप गुड-गुड अरुणेश
नहीं बोलते रहेंगे गुड-गुड अपडेट योर मोरल
मोरल मॉडेस्ट नहीं बोलते इधर प्रमेय
रेगुलर थिंग जर्मन में भी एक्जेक्टली सेम
है ऐसे ही रेगुलर टीम कौन सी है देखो
गुडबाय असर आम विस्टन गुड बेहतर आम
वेस्टर्न है
है मतलब मेरे यार लॉट ऑफ मैं अब माइकल
मेयर मतलब मनोरम स्थल मतलब मोस्ट और एक
टिपिकल जर्मन स्टाइल है यह गैर गैर मतलब
है पीली लीवर मतलब और ज्यादा है पीली आम
लिस्ट एकदम ज्यादा है पीली अभी के लिए हम
कोई इसकी इतनी जरूरत नहीं है पहले दो
ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट है अग्नि एवं गुटखा यूज
करके देखते हैं फिर से एक बार में को
पर्फेक्ट यूज करूंगा देखो पर फैक्ट्री में
यूज करता हूं कि विनोद और ब्रेड थे हमको
देर दास का यूज नहीं करना पड़ता दिनों
अजमेर रीजन पड़ता है ओके सिंपल है फिर फॉर
थिस गुड फॉर थिस क्यूट को किस शहर को DSC
को केस्ट योर वोट विप सी को किस बैटर दैन
किडनी को किस ट्विस्ट सरल टिप्स को इस
पेस्ट को सिस्टम वेस्टर्न सिडनी कोई चेंज
नहीं है फिर भी इस तरह याद रखना कि
सिमरा अभी डिफरेंट एक छोटा सा चीज बता
देता हूं कि अब हम देखो क्या सीख रहे हैं
कि जब एडजेक्टिव अलग है तब देख रहे हैं कि
जब गुड बॉय कि जब गुडबाय जो बन सकते हैं
वह कभी नहीं सीख रहे हैं वह एग्जीक्यूटिव
एंड डूइंग यह वह गिवन कंसेप्ट है क्योंकि
जब मन में भी हिंदी की तरह नौटंकी नाइन से
पहले जो एडजेक्टिव आता है वह थोड़ा चेंज
होता है वह हम भी व में देखने वाले डोंट
वरी ई वांट न राइट नऊ वे अरे फोकसिंग
एडजेक्टिव फॉर्म तो एडजेक्टिव फॉर्म सबको
समझ में ऐड एकदम सिंपल कंसेप्ट है नॉर्मल
ही केयर लगाना अब स्टैंड लगाना कंपैरेटिव
है तो यार सुपरलेटिव तो आम और स्टैंड बहुत
छोटी-छोटी जगहों पर थोड़े से चेंज होती
हैं कईं लगता है कहीं इधर-उधर चेंज होता
है और घूंट और तिल को बढ़ा चेंज होता है
और यूज कैसे करना इक्वल है तो जौ हुई
बेअसर है या फिर अगर ज्यादा खैर दूसरी चीज
से तो आईएस लगाना और हम है तो
कि अब लास्ट नाम लेकर स्टैंड लंबी लिस्ट
सिंपल स्टेप आपको प्रिडिक्टिव ऊपर है तो
उसका फॉर्म बनाना एकदम सिंपल है मुझे आशा
है कि आप सब कोई कंस्ट्रक्टिव से पर समझ
में आई होगी हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड
में धन्यवाद